this video continues our epic
investigation into induction and today
we're going back to question six from
the 1988 math olympiad it's pretty
legendary we've discussed it on the
channel before on more than one occasion
but zvezda was one of the few people who
as a student managed to crack it and she
used you guessed it induction
one of the iconic problems from the
international math olympiad australia
88. brady you have done videos on it but
i was there as a student i solved the
problem and my teammate emmanuel
attanasov he got the brilliancy award
for his solution
my solution
involved induction
and the cubic
polynomial his solution involved
induction in a quadratic polynomial so
it was simpler
and we will talk about emmanuel's
solution now so we're going to look at
the way that he did it not the way you
did it yes mine was pretty close it had
this extra linear factor
which i don't know how i concocted but
it was there and it's a perfectly legal
solution but to this day i remember
emmanuel's solution were you jealous
afterwards when you found out that the
two of you did it differently and he's
won the brilliancy prize did you think
oh i wish i'd done it that or were you
still happy you know never i remember
talking with demon wheel about
vaguely similar problems before the
olympiad
and he was asking me some questions
about them so he must have understood
something i told him better than i
understood it myself
and
actually for me it took
only 20 minutes to solve this problem
again
i had never seen something exactly like
this before i don't know what overcame
me and number theory was never my forte
i love for example geometry
algebra but number theory and all of a
sudden you get this moment in your life
where 20 minutes defines your future
because
after the olympiad a year later i came
to the united states on a scholarship
how was i selected among
thousands of students from sofie
university on only
seven scholarships for bulgarian
students to come to the united states
the australian committee
wrote a recommendation letter for me and
they said that was the only girl who
solved this iconic problem take her
and here i am standing in front of you
and
looking back
and understanding that was the moment of
no return this is what brought me to the
united states we were super happy for
emmanuel
to get the brilliancy award in fact lots
of brilliancy awards have gotten to
bulgarian students so that wasn't a
total surprise
what's the question
yes so you start with two numbers
which are stubbornly given to you as
natural numbers and you will see why i
call stubbornly you are also given
that the following ratio a squared plus
b squared over 1 plus a b and i'm going
to call it r for ratio happens to be an
integer well okay it must be a natural
number because these are natural numbers
here okay what do we have to show
proof
that this ratio r
is a perfect square so what does a
perfect square mean it means that it's
something like 1 square to 2 squared or
3 squared etc etc and squared
for some natural number n
so for instance you cannot get here
for r um i don't know seven fourths
because that's not an integer and in
fact we're not even interested in this
but
more than that you cannot get seven
because seven is not a perfect square so
our job is to explain why you cannot get
seven why it has to be a perfect square
and how old were you when you were sat
down and had to answer this question
we'll prove this i think i was 18.
now
what we're going to do is something
non-trivial we have
two variables here a and b r isn't given
by the problem as variable i just put it
there but it turns out that it's r that
is going to give us an anchor for
solving the problem while a and b are
going to vary throughout our solution r
is going to be fixed and that's an
unexpected twist so we're going to
fix this ratio r
and then we will simplify
the pairs a b
that give the same ratio r
so if i start with one pair that is
given to me
i will somehow reduce it to a very very
simple pair let me not give away how
simple that will be that will again give
exactly the same ratio r and the
conclusion will immediately follow okay
what are the ground rules here the new
numbers a and b n that we find those
pairs so let me just once again
emphasize they have to give the same
ratio so if i plug them into this
formula i should get the same r those
numbers i'm going to allow them to be
non-negative integers so not just
natural numbers from 1 2 and so on but
i'm going to add a 0 to that because
this is my creation i can do whatever i
like i'm the boss so am and b n will be
possibly zeros they will still be
integers and to cut this abstraction and
make it very specific i'm just going to
give you an example suppose i say my
ratio is four four is good
4 is 2 squared so this should work and
what number c and b could i take let's
say i take a should be
30 and b
1 12. all right so this is just an
example let us see if this works so we
plug this in oh my goodness look at this
huge number you can check me at home and
what do you think this ratio is i think
it's four
let's check that four times one is four
two
yeah yeah okay this works okay all right
so that's our starting pair i want to
simplify how can i do this so now take
your original fraction here and rewrite
it differently
next i'm going to pull everything to the
left hand side but i will start
regrouping things let me see if you can
follow this
r times a b is right here pull to the
other side and then the remainder is b
squared minus r and this whole thing has
to be zero now if i write it like this
this looks like a quadratic equation and
so i will replace a
by an unknown x
but leave absolutely everything else the
same and so what this equation is is
quadratic so it will have two roots x1
and x2 now x1 we already know at least
one of them has to be a a satisfies this
equation and so there is another root x2
which um let's call it a1 so there is
this phantom second root of this
equation
what kind of a number is a1 i would
really like it to be a non-negative
integer so it can fit into my scheme
well
i can immediately say that it's an
integer why
because the task formulas tell you that
if you add the two roots of your
quadratic equation you'd better get
negative of this coefficient which turns
out to be rb and from here x2 this other
phantom root
is an integer because everything
involved here is already an integer
could this x to be negative i don't want
that well one easy way to show that it's
non-negative is to go back to the
original ratio and plug it in now
after you backtrack everything you can
replace everywhere a by x by x 2. so x 2
should work here too so in other words
if i do x 2 squared plus b squared over
1 plus b
x 2 that should be our original r this
is supposed to be non-negative in fact
positive this is our four well the top
is positive so the bottom has to be
positive
but
could x to actually be negative here
because b is already positive x 2 is an
integer if i start subtracting integers
from 1 things will go sour because i
could
hit 0 which i don't want in the
denominator i could get negative
altogether in the denominator
but the whole ratio is positive so there
is no way this x2 could be negative
at worst it could be zero all right so
x2 is not just an integer it's a
non-negative integer so this this
phantom twin is good for us and so let's
try to find it in our situation 30 here
is our a and 1 12 is b
so what was the formula
for x 2
there is the formula so x 2
will be
r
b
minus
x 1 which in our case r is 4 b is 1 12
and x 1 is a which is 30 all right but
what is that guys
this
doesn't look good this looks more
complicated it looks larger right
it looks something like uh 4 18.
so what i have obtained is that the pair
418 instead of a and i'm going to keep b
will also yield this ratio 4. but
instead of simplifying my problem i
actually complicated it i got larger
numbers
so what am i going to do
who said that i have to tackle a how
about we try to replace b i mean if you
look at this pair it's more reasonable
to try to reduce the larger of the two
numbers 112.
but absolutely the same analysis that we
did for a
works for b
so if i rewrite this equation as b
squared minus r a b
plus so i'm just flip flopping a and b
and now b is going to be my unknown and
i will call it just y and now i have two
roots one of them is b
and the other one let's call it b1
so what is b1 in this case we will have
again vieta's formulas
but mine did this time i'm getting r a
not rb
so this phantom second root is r a minus
y one
so r a minus your b
uh-huh
will that save the day so now we're
going to
hope we can
simplify this 1 12.
all right well right here what do we
have y2 will be remember r is 4
what is a
a is 30
b is 1
12. oh this looks hopeful one twenty
minus one twelve that's eight
eight is better than one twelfth
so what i have just produced for you
is another pair thirty comma 8
that also gives this ratio now i'm sure
at this point you guys don't believe me
let's quickly compute 30 squared plus 8
squared over 1 plus 30 times 8. all
right what's that 964
divided by 241
is this
4
yep it is 4.
so this pair
gives exactly the same ratio as the
other two pairs ah
now you feel better
so what am i going to do
we can see that we could reduce the
larger number down so can't we now
reduce 30 down let's try and i know the
formula for reducing the a's
it was our first derived one so if i
want to find now the twin to 30
i'm gonna do four times
my b
is eight
so four times eight minus
and x one is thirty ah this looks
splendid it's two
we are getting there brady we're almost
there
there we go so what is the new pair
instead of 30 we put two
b survives no change and again you are
doubting me does this give the same 4 of
course 2 squared plus 8 squared over 1
plus 2 times 8 what's this 68 over 17
bingo that's 4. so
which of the two numbers should i now
reduce two or eight eight eight of
course eight and four eight it's that
formula here so what do we do
we do y two is
four times
a is 2
minus
8 for y1
what is that
that is 0.
and that's why actually the problem
works because you get to this forbidden
zero
the creators of the problem deliberately
didn't give you the possibility of
plugging in zero here they said that a
and b have to be natural numbers but we
go beyond
what they gave us and we create our own
world of solutions slightly extended so
what am i talking about here this 2a
turns into
two states and eight becomes zero
does this give our four and here i doubt
anyone will have any doubts there is
nothing to come from here and i'm
dividing by one so the only thing that's
left is 2 squared which is our 4 but 2
squared was our original a squared
that's really the reason we are getting
perfect squares because once you start
with any pair of numbers that work for
the problem you will
reduce it one by one until you get to a
pair that contains a zero
and then you wave the victory flag what
was it the checkered flag something you
brady you fill me in on check it for egg
yeah the checkered flag that's right
now where is induction in this
i don't see infinitely many steps here
these were finitely many
but i don't know what the initial pair
is
i cannot just argue by this example it
starts somewhere
and i need the general
reasoning to show me that this process
actually works brings you to a pair that
has a zero in it
and it doesn't go on forever here i
actually want it to stop
so this induction will be finite
induction you have only finitely many
dominoes
and that stops the process the moment
one of our numbers turns into zero we
stop the car and say we are there we
have arrived i need another sheet of
paper okay so just so i'm clear the rate
so the ratio is not always four no the
ratio will be the square of whatever yes
that's right this was just for our
example so we can clearly see concretely
how this is working before we get to the
variables
so now the proof
what we just did was a particular
example
i agree very convincing one
but we need to wrap this in a technical
package so that it fits in our vehicle
of induction
it is the inductive step here that needs
to be confirmed that it actually is
always works for any variables not just
for our particular numbers here is our
ratio and i'm going to fix it as r r is
some integer positive integer a and b
are natural numbers and what we did is
we rewrote this
as an equation
that equation was quadratic like this
then we replaced a by x and we created
two
roots one of which was a
and the other one by the task formulas
turned out to be rb minus the other root
or rb minus a and then we did exactly
the same thing with a and b switch so
instead of x i am using y and now we
create two roots here
one of them is b
the other one is r a minus the previous
root or r a minus b okay so now what do
we do we start with a pair a b
that yields this ratio r i'm going to
conjecture not conjecture but assume for
a moment by contradiction
that our method fails
it means that if i attempt to replace a
by its twin root a2 but keep b i'm going
to be enlarging in other words a2
will be bigger than a and at the same
time if i keep a but replace b
by its twin
i'm again increasing or even equal so in
other words i'm not doing anything
so
assume for a moment that this is what's
happening we don't want this to happen
we want actually to go down not to go up
okay where is our contradiction let us
go back into the task formulas and they
said that the sum of the two roots x1
plus x2 is rb and the sum of the other
two roots is our a one of those roots
here
let's say x1 that was a and one of those
two roots is b so b plus y two so uh
what
have we done here we have just written
via task formulas but those are just one
part of vieta's formulas there is a
second vietnam formula
which concerns the products of those two
roots
so what is the product of the roots of a
quadratic equation it is the last
coefficient over the first one but here
the first one is one so this is going to
be equal to b squared minus r and
similarly for the other quadratic
equation the two roots should multiply
to a squared minus r again this is
vieta's formulas okay now i'm going to
continue
x1 was a
and then we got x2
y1 was b
and we got y2 okay we are almost there
what did we assume about x2 x2 was this
a2 we assumed that x2 was greater than
or equal to a
and everything is positive so this is
greater than a times a which is a
squared and we did exactly the same
thing for b that was y2 was b2 that is b
greater than or equal to b times bb
squared the problem is that i have on
the left hand side something that's
actually smaller than what's on the
right hand side but i i'm claiming
exactly the opposite because if i add
everything what will i get a squared
plus b squared minus 2r on the left is
greater than or equal to
a squared plus b squared
and
that is not going to happen because that
means that 0 is greater than or equal to
2r or r is negative
but
that's
in contradiction with what's given we
avoided
ruining our proof we actually showed
that it works
so
with our pair a b
we cannot be going upstairs at least one
of these two pairs must be smaller and
you can prove for homework that actually
exactly one pair will be smaller and the
other one would be larger and when they
say smaller i don't mean that the
numbers both of the numbers are smaller
that one of the numbers is smaller and
the other one is fixed and that's all we
need and so with this proof at hand you
will start creating a chain of pairs
each of which gives r and the numbers
inside now
could potentially be zero because of our
formulas via task formulas but that's
okay the only thing that they cannot be
is negative and so you will keep on
going what does it mean keep on going it
means i'm using induction
so keep on applying this algorithm until
one of the numbers
becomes zero and i don't know ahead of
time which one it will be
whether
a or b will turn into zero but the
important thing
is that the ratio is kept the same and
so far i haven't said anything about the
ratio at least on this brown paper
but we are ready to show that the ratio
is a perfect square because if i plug in
any one of those two pairs into our
expression this is what we get in
actuality
you're not going to have both of them
you're going to have just one of them
but i'm writing them for completeness
here and this is going to be r so r is
going to be equal either
to be n squared
or a n squared
which is a perfect square
and now we are truly
done after finitely many steps for
homework you can actually compute
what is the largest number of steps
you can ever have another homework brady
do they give them homework no i don't i
want to know what the number is
because i love numbers on number five
will you whisper it in my ear later
because or is it is it like a fight
really depends it depends so it could be
vertical yeah if those numbers a and b
are large you can go many steps
but um as you saw in our original
example at the very end we were going
very fast
at any rate
what i wanted also to say is that you
can go backwards you can start with any
pair of numbers one of them zero so zero
b or a zero
and backtrack with via task formulas
those guys here r a minus b r b minus a
backtrack and create a recursive
formulas for all of those pairs that
actually satisfy this problem
and you know investigate and study them
but for our purposes for for solving
this problem at the olympiad what we
cared is that we hit a wall we hit this
zero for one or the other variable and
that's where we put a full stop to the
induction
you were basically kids this is amazing
though aspiring to be adults
at that point yes yes apparently terence
tower who is like you know the most
famous mathematician in the world he was
also at this olympiad and he didn't get
it he couldn't do it
he wasn't just the olympian he was
actually in my room
yes so all of the participants in the
imo were split into several rooms and i
may have been even the only girl in my
room i don't remember but when i looked
around it looked like only boys i had
slept really poorly the night before and
i basically didn't sleep i was so tired
i knew that if i don't solve the
problems very quickly i'm just not going
to survive the test and they give you
four and a half hours for three problems
every day so this is day two
and our problem that we discussed was
number six so one of the three problems
i was reading about an hour and 20
minutes
done with all three problems i don't
know what possessed me i had never done
this before i attempted to give my
papers and go and sleep because i was so
tired they told me for security reasons
you cannot leave
okay so then i returned to my chair and
i fell asleep
i actually slept for probably about two
hours
which was very nasty of me because some
of the boys around me knew me from the
previous olympiad in cuba so they knew
that i would not fall asleep unless i
had solved all the problems but i
couldn't help it i was just out and so
then i wake up look around everyone is
still continuing to solve the problems
and then again i attempt to leave about
an hour early so
finally they let me go
and
on walking outside my coaches saw me on
the way in greece weston why did you
leave early well if they had known how
early i could have left
later on that day as i'm walking
someone is pulling me you know by my
skirts he's pulling my skirt and i look
down and
it's this star participant an australian
representative teron style because he
was very young oh he was super young
yeah so any rate he was in my room he
obviously remembered what happened he
witnessed all of this and so he's
pulling my skirt and saying how did you
solve number six
and i start saying i use the induction
on the product
he says thank you turns around and runs
away
amazing so the word induction
on the product that expression was
enough for him
to
go and complete the rest of the solution
actually i don't know if he completed it
but at least that he did not want any
more hints that was it for terence
if you'd like to hear terence tower
himself talking about question six check
out our interview with him here on
numberphile and we haven't quite
finished with induction yet we've got
another video on our number file 2
channel there will be a link on the
screen and in the video description
the famous question yes
what what what's your recollection of it
now and why and you you didn't get it
right no i did not get it right how do
you feel about it i uh
well you know you win some you lose some
uh oh boy i uh
i have it so long ago now i don't
remember much about it i